brothers and beats
gentlemen we're live we are officially
live special uh show today episode
number 97 pvd podcast with gerard adam
and
the one and only ronin from call of duty
aka two lamb 23 years in the military
20-year special ops
the guys got an incredible story of
escape in vietnam on a boat while living
at a refugee camp how russians came and
saved them i mean literally this is a
story out of a movie cannot wait to
share that story with him i've been
following this stuff for a while this
guy's a badass every time his name comes
up
everybody has great things to say about
him so it's an honor to have you on here
brother truly it's great to have you on
here
thanks for coming out thank you for
having me on yes absolutely so you know
we got we got a lot of stories we're
going to cover obviously uh i woke up
last night uh uh
i was uh doing my business i had a few
people over and we're sitting and have a
conversation until one o'clock in the
morning i get this exciting message kai
i've never seen adam this excited about
trump opening up a social media site oh
yeah and wanting to be a part of it and
then that's what we're going with i
think it's important for us to talk
about the traumatic event you had this
week it's a lot of trauma uh a friend
lent you a car some stuff happened there
the audience needs to know and then
we'll talk about some serious issues
outside of that on shipping crisis which
you have a lot of experience with we'll
talk afghanistan
we'll talk about what's going on with
the swat team quitting navy seals
quitting because they don't want to take
the vaccine and we want to get your
insight since that's the world you were
in for 20 years special ops
barry weiss had some interesting
comments to make to stelter on who told
you you are not allowed to cover certain
stories and she laid into him we'll talk
about america's re-education camp
uh and a few other stories that we may
get into carl icahn made a few comments
this week that i think it's a good to
cover kiyosaki was at the birthday party
yeah you had a chance to spend so he was
having a great time he had a great time
he had
women flocking to him
was it woman flocking to him like they
were actually attracted to this guy
maybe he was he was doing good
it was very hard to get a word in with
uh with with richmond rich dad him yeah
poor dad much easier to get away with
rich dad i'm not gonna ask a lot a lot
of people want to have the rich aren't
trying to talk to you we had a good time
listen you want to work with the service
now the birthday party started at seven
okay and we thought you know maybe like
you know
you can tell people's stamina on how it
works and whose stamina can last right
you had not had any sleep because the
night before you were spending way too
much time reading books
and uh so with with your friends avid
river yeah so
it goes happy birthday by the way
appreciate you you see the first crew
leave second crew leave third crew leave
fourth crew leave fifth crew leave
by the sixth seventh eighth crew they're
not leaving you gotta kick them out it's
like listen guys you got to go and that
was us
four o'clock in the morning
i'm not leaving so having said that too
would you be the early crew to leave the
lake crew you're staying late for the
party what's your what's your party
vibes i'm the first one to leave i have
to use the restroom and then i'll get up
the irish goodbye
irish goodbye two's out yeah
there were people waiting outside for
ubers and uh chris and i were walking in
with five
can you imagine gerard was the white
club bully that night have a white club
i'm good jordan you're gonna be drinking
yourself
are you still on only on 10th date have
you guys had an 11th and a 12th and or
13th what's the number because so the
irish exit
change the subject that's right yeah
listen personally
that liked him first of all not only did
she like him she was attractive yeah
wait a minute
getting nervous because gerard gerard's
one of those guys he just can't wait to
get married he wants to have a family he
wants to sell he's one of those guys
family value is kind of a guy yeah but
anyways let's change the topic since
it's making too much pressure for it
turn all red weird too
i've never seen him turn around
today today today i appreciate all the
love appreciate all the birthday wishes
thank you today is about two
uh two for for the audience that doesn't
know maybe they only know you from call
of duty maybe they've seen a couple of
uh interviews stories that you down
where whether it's with the knife
whether it's how to handle the gun
whether it's how to handle a weapon
which is your specialty once you take a
few minutes and share with us your story
your background how you went from where
you were at at the age of 2 3 when you
you your brother your mom the whole
story to come into the states
share your story a little bit with the
audience yeah thank you patrick i mean
it's it's through the struggles that we
find our strength and that's that's
that's truly what my life is about i was
born in vietnam i was born on a cold
cement floor um in the basement saigon
hospital my mother shielded my body from
incoming authority fire in my mourning
my birth at this stage of the war you
know american troops uh had left vietnam
and uh this left a devastating impact on
people itself and i was born on the
losing side of war
mid 70s when is this i was born in 74 74
yeah so american troops already left
vietnam 75 it was when saigon
failed vietnam um you know everybody
always talks about you know vietnam
reminds them of afghanistan you know
everything that's going on and and truly
that's what it was guys because uh we
were oppressed we were
my uncles that served alongside
americans they were in prison they were
brought out to the re-education camps
these were labor camps torture camps
uh when when i received my uncle in the
states
he was in prison for 15 years when i
received him in the states he had no
skin on the bottom of his foot they
skinned the bottom of his foot they
broke him as a human being
as an individual i mean literally he
laid in the corner
of the room he wouldn't even lay in bed
because he was that uh dramatically uh
traumatized
um at three years old we escaped on a
wooden fishing boat you know this this
boat probably fits about 45 people that
night
that morning that we escaped we were
fitting over 100 people in that boat and
guys we the the the trip was to come out
of vietnam and
into uh malaysia right so two day trip
that was rough on this fishing boat
on this fishing boat right so we had to
sleep on the bottom deck my i was a
little child three years old but we had
to sleep sitting up so think about like
you don't even feel your limbs anymore
your legs right because everybody's just
overstuffed so
uh the pie tree was going on during that
time so a lot of bandits pirates robbers
from surrounding countries it was a
lucrative business for them to stop the
boats
uh killing the men raped the women and
tortured the children it was common
practice amongst the fleeing refugees to
carry poison within their belongings
and the refugees would poison their
children if if they tripped in for us as
opposed to subjecting like a life of
slavery life of slavery uh human
trafficking
torture
the bandits were known to to torture the
children um
we seen just a thought about thought of
that it's just you know parents carrying
poison to prevent their kids from going
through that level of struggle right i
mean that's just trauma at this highest
level please continue so we we uh we
navigated out of vietnam um my mother
said he was a um
a navy captain so he knew the tactics
you know and how to get uh past the
pirates basically shut off the engines
quiet down the motor and he uh he
x-filled out there uh at night you know
undercover darkness we went into the
shores of malaysia and and this time the
malaysian coast guard they shot at us
they stopped us
no more refugees in their country you
know um
so basically they they hooked and
anchors back on with a line they
forcefully drug us back out into the
south china sea
uh shot her motor cut the line and left
us there to die now what i want what i
want to say is guys we it was a two-day
planned trip
so there was hardly any water there was
hardly any supplies it was hardly any
food we didn't plan that
so what i'm saying is now we're stranded
now this is a desperate survival
situation in the middle of the south
china sea you know so people are dying
um my mother said that we we drifted
roughly a month
we're out to see so people are dying
people are getting thrown overseas
people are getting sick
and my mother she she's contemplating on
that poison
because you're three years old at this
time i was three and are you is are
there other family members of yours with
you my brother my brother my biological
father and my mother and your brother
you're three he's seven right if i
recall your brother you're a baby i mean
like the seven-year-old at least kind of
knows what's going on you've got no clue
what's going on i assume right yeah you
know i study the mind later on in life
that means i i study how the mind works
and you know if you suffer from
something so traumatic and if you can
really uh slow down the analytical
mindset and get into your subconscious
you know i do have visions
of that
trip
you know it's small little splashes but
long story short were drifting out of
the ocean people are dying people are
getting sick but
we're drinking urine i mean it was it
was a desperate survival situation and
my mother said that she can't play on
the poison that she woke us up one night
and she contemplated his poison and we
had ulcers growing on her legs i mean
there's no
blood circulation in our legs think
about how overstuffed that boat was you
know malnourished and my mother gave us
everything she had the water she had the
food she had but now she was down to her
last bucket of water
and um
she contemplated this poison
she said later on you know she woke my
brother up and made him drink half of
the bucket of water and she made me
drink
and then she cried she couldn't do it
she couldn't kill us
you know so um
it was a miracle that's transpired at
night because um
that's the night that we got caught up
in a storm
a huge tropical storm think about like
the south china sea patrick right huge
tropical a fishing boat
these waves could easily
tip this over crazy can you pull up the
south china sea for a location reference
yeah so it's it's it's crazy just to
think about it and this storm this storm
saved us
see it it washed us
into
the lat long coronations of this route
where a russian supply boat was exiting
out of it now if that's not a god story
i'm going to tell you that's a god story
man
the south china sea is a huge ocean
and we were drugged
back out into the south china sea
and then somehow through the coordinates
of a lat long
a
russian supply boat intercepted us and
that right there is a million and one
changes that's the type of thing that
happens in a movie and you're like no
way that what's the chances that that
ship intersects them yeah that's
and somehow if you guys had gone to
cambodia it would have been even worse
for you i mean at that time i mean you
know the killing fields of cambodia had
gotten insane
um
so they um the russian supply boat now
where i want to i want to paint this
picture guys because the russian
ideology the socialist ideology is what
ripped the part of our country right
right the marxists
can you mind two sharing the story of
how
uh the the leader uh at that time came
to america for help they turned him down
to bring westernized philosophy back to
his country then russia said yes then he
brought communism down to
vietnam and everything can you mind
sharing that story yeah so you know the
french are trying to call on the
indochina war what people don't
understand is they think the vietnam war
is only the american involvement
my mother was born in war yeah that was
france's mess right the indo-china war
like
by the time the vietnam war ended for my
parents they've been at war for
close to 20 years oh wow
right and that's what people don't
understand so what patrick was saying is
ho chi minh came in and they were trying
to colonize he you know he started
seeing a divide between his country
right vietnam so you had the south
vietnam you had the north it's clearly a
divide in ideology right so uh he first
he came to uh the americans he asked for
help but we didn't want any involvement
there
because we didn't want to go against our
french allies and they did have a point
the friend the the french were were
being brutal with their plantations
the french were
they they were colonizing america like
they were colonizing uh
you know vietnam like they it was still
africa and america centuries before it
was imperialism from the 1800s still
going on imperialism yeah it was
plantations there was slavery
yes but what what they what they didn't
understand was the the vietnamese people
they're trained with the
warfare of sanju
right that means unconventional work as
a green beret i'm telling you i'm a
master on conventional warfare we found
our independence as americans in the
revolutionary war under
unconventional warfare
so when the friends try to colonize
they're facing an unconventional warfare
type of army sanju type of tactics so
they're having a hard time and
ho chi minh went to americans and asked
for help we didn't have any interest
there he went to the russians obviously
that that communist ideology was uh
embedded into ho chi minh he only cared
about uniting his country under one
country again
right so communism came uh the the
russians started supporting the the
communist ideology the north vietnamese
grew to the armies and they raised
unconventional warfare against a
conventional force of americans how long
does gorilla tactics need to you know be
implemented before that actually is
conventional warfare like at this at
this point there's no
standing armies lining up across the
battlefield from each other anymore
right like isn't all unconventional
warfare today we're all war for today
technically unconventional
uh i mean yeah uh the warfare that i
thought in is very unconventional
because you know there's no declared two
sides of the army right you're not
not you know you're in this uniform in
this uniform this is the battlefield no
it's the battlefield is in the united
states the battlefield is in yemen
in iraq afghanistan all these different
areas the battlefield for for me was
the secret wars
you know so
and that's what i mean so when when
vietnam fell to that
um
you know they started raising
unconventional warfare they knew look
guys warfare is expensive we know that
right after afghanistan iraq warfare is
expensive so the chinese if you study
their their tactics under sanju
warfare is expensive they'll never
employ soldiers
to put a footprint there for too long
americans do and that's our mistake
right so we employ americans overseas
we're funding americans to fight these
wars right overseas how expensive is it
to to keep americans overseas how
expensive is the ford ammunition
supplies uh weapons you know the uh the
assets like the drones potentially
intentionally so though i mean the
industrial military complex has made a
lot of people mega wealthy and they've
never had to step foot outside of dc so
so when the country failed to uh to
communism um
eventually it failed to communism
and americans pulled out because it was
expensive war it was an unpopular war it
was an unpopular war because up until
then the the media censored everything
right so do you think about world war ii
right think about war two war one the
philippines all these different wars you
watch that the media censors everything
it was until the vietnam war was when
they allow reporters to come in and
unfortunately guys hey look when you see
women and children dying in warfare and
you see to true realities of war is ugly
and it smells and it stinks
so when america is getting a snapshot of
i don't know
a
american killing a civilian is it this
event
because i've been in countries where
rebels would come in and wipe out a
whole village
and have an eight-year-old is he
now
a militant or is he still a child
because he's just killed his parents
you see it's a different world what's
what i'm saying to you so
you know when vietnam fell to that and
the americans they could not sustain
this
unpopular very expensive war that's
unconventional they're not used in fact
the green braids and the special forces
were developed to combat
you know this insurgency
you know that's where it came from
so when that country fell to it ho chi
minh was able to establish a more
communist regime and his main concern
once he took over the country south
vietnam was to make sure that our
leaders would never rise up to power
again like afghanistan
think about like anybody who hold
position to power
they're murdered
they're killed right so the same with
the vietnamese if anybody holds position
power like my uncles had they were
officers they were drugged out to the
camps and tortured
you know we were oppressed simply for
what opposing ideas ideas that they did
not agree with ideas that contradicted
what they believed in well like you know
sarajevo bosnia you know people
different ideologies they will wipe out
a whole existence because you don't
believe what they believe yeah and
dissension it you know disagreement seen
as dissension it's not seen as civil
discourse one of the great things about
the way our country was founded it was
founded on civil discourse let's have
this disagreement let's have the two
houses argue it out and then let's have
it you know then let's you know have a
law as opposed to the top-down you know
decree mandate from the king right so
but i i want to say this because when i
came over to america right you know
because i lived like i lived in a
refugee camp for a year and a half guys
you know in indonesia and it was a grass
hut in the middle of the jungle you have
to survive you have to live off the land
they don't give you
anything hipsters do that for vacation
now too they do
yeah it's very spiritual it's very
spiritual because you know what's really
weird is that you we are all successful
men we we we value certain things but i
tell you man when i went into these
third world countries and these villages
where there was nothing
they were happy
so what are we doing wrong
we're looking at the externals to be
happy
you know it goes underneath samurai
teachings it goes underneath the print
but we look for the externals to make
ourselves happy these days right
so i think that's what's wrong with
america and what's wrong with a modern
day society if you go to these thorough
countries they are happy because they're
around their families and around their
friends let me ask a couple questions
based on where you just went right now
because we would just want a completely
different place which is good it opens
it up so
i'm watching your body language as
you're telling your story i get two
sides here i see a side if i didn't know
you know i met you for the first time
and i saw you at a restaurant
i'd say this guy's a
gentle
sweet
you know
the way you talk calm all that stuff
right on the way you speak i don't know
if you guys get that feeling that's the
feeling i get a very sweet gentle side
right
how are you hiding that rage
inside
how did you do that because there's no
way in the flipping
world that you
are going to be able to live that kind
of a life have that kind of trauma have
that kind of animosity on what was done
where nobody can describe that to you
this is your life this is not a movie
this is not a book this is not a article
we're reading
how are you managing that rage because
the same way as your gentle
on the other side special ops i know
what it is you know special ops i hung
out with those guys you know whether it
was delta i was about to become 18 to 18
delta with fifth group at fort campbell
kentucky i went and interviewed a lot of
guys like you and i said i'm going to go
a different direction i got out of the
military
how do you manage that gentle side and
the rage side
you know patrick i'm going to put you in
my worst day
you know it's through the struggles
right when i said no i'm gonna put you
through this day you know i i was uh i
was eight years old
and people always ask me too what's your
first memories of america i'll tell you
my mother took me to a grocery store and
she she bought all this food and look
that
i don't mean anything to you guys but
i'm telling you when you starve and
you're in rescue camps for a year and a
half that means everything
and then she was so happy and she took
she took me out it was mother and sunday
you know we were loading the groceries
into the car and this man came up to me
and he spit in my face and he flicked my
mom off and he told me to go home he
called me [ __ ]
this is in america eight years old
carolina
that was my first memories
of america
unpopular vietnam war and i was the
image of an unpopular vietnam war
and
when i was eight
i went to school i was very poor had
holes all my clothes
you know we uh we live in a four-part
town i was reminded how poor i was every
day
and uh we went in school it was
substitute teacher day and um my name is
pronounced
in vietnamese right but i say two lambs
so you guys don't mess up my vietnamese
name so um it was sub 2 teacher day he
called my name and obviously he said it
wrong and everybody made fun of me
everybody's throwing papers at me
remind me how poor i was and there was
this bully he made fun of me made it
slanted eyes and we we both got in
trouble right i don't know how i got in
trouble i got in trouble i know he went
down to the principal's office and the
principal sat us down he told our
parents need to come pick us up
my mom didn't drive at a time so i knew
i was gonna be there for a while and
then the bully's mother came in first
and uh she demanded no what's wrong the
principal stood up and he looked over he
goes your son caught a boy right there a
[ __ ]
i sat back down
the mudder went in the corner she picked
up her son walked over to me and you
know how somebody stands there you have
to look up because i was looking at the
ground was already defeated
i looked up and she said my son is right
you don't belong here and you need to go
back home
to your country
you're eight years old
i tried so hard i hyperventilated and
principals say boy you're gonna cry like
that you need to go in the hall
and that night i came home i didn't even
talk to my mom i was so upset
and my mother came in
i didn't even eat dinner she came in she
sat down next to me she said son there
will be the bad days
but what do you learn from it
never ask me what everything that
happened or anything's wrong i knew at
that point
that i got tired of being this huge weak
human being you know i was escaped from
war i found you know a face deaf a faced
you know refugee camps
and i got tired of being this weak human
being
so i made a promise to myself that day i
was going to be stronger than hate but
what's that even look like right so what
what what what you see in me patrick is
i have rage
it's there and i can switch it on and
off at any second
but it's like a weapon i can safety that
gun
right because i drive as aware i drive
off of compassion
so so let's let's go through this okay
uh when you when you said that i'm
trying to see how that trauma affected
me i'm a kid i come to the states
uh when i came here was seventh grade so
whatever seventh grade is i'm 12 years
old and i'm coming here and my english
sucked so for me they would i had a hard
time pronouncing uh
government i would say government i had
a hard time pronouncing wednesday i
would say wednesday
because of that end that's there it
really screws the whole thing up whoever
came up with that name they need to be
fired as a you know right now uh there
was a show called gilligan's island i
would say gilligan's island because that
s is there why the hell would you put an
s there what's the problem with these
guys here right i'm sure you struggled
with lasagna lasagna that was easy
because my mother made lasagna but fresh
off the boat you know hey you're fresh
you're phobia you're fresh off the boat
i'm like i'm going to buy the damn boat
one day you guys are pissing me off
right but that rage was either going
into humor to lighten the load because
you have to be like hey funny all this
other stuff you know it's the humor side
to kind of calm me down a lot of times
comedians have lived a very difficult
life what did you do with it like did
you put it in martial arts did you put
it at 13 14 years old in sports did you
put it in fighting kids like were you
the guy we had a guy in school's name
was andy asian guy
and uh uh this guy would walk so calm
one time a guy called him something a
good friend of mine
he didn't just beat the guy he almost
killed the guy we had to pick him up we
couldn't even pick this guy up he was
like going to kill this kid if we didn't
stop him
the right and he went from a calm sweet
kid to a guy capable of killing somebody
where did you release your tension and
anger into what was that for you as a
young teenager
you know i i um i i was raised my
stepfather was uh special forces my own
cool special forces so i was raised in
fayetteville outside fort bragg the
biggest
special operations second right more
commandos walked there
than anywhere in the united states i was
raised around that but when you asked me
what my outlet was
you know patrick i was beaten
i was bullied my whole my whole
all the way to high school
um
my outlet was um
you know my spending time with my father
the special forces
but i knew let me bring you to this day
so i i was being picked on with spit on
clothes you know being ripped off me
just remind how poor i was and my uncle
special forces americans better he was
the one who funded our paperwork to get
us to the united states
american special forces he was an
officer his g base guy overran vietnam
he got stabbed by sks he backed out this
guy's
he's an amazing american and my uncle
picked me up right
and he he drove me and he must have said
something's wrong with me that day
because he he said something i just out
of blue
he said you know too
there'll be days
that people are going to spit on you and
they're going to judge you're going to
flick you off and they're going to say
you don't belong here
you need to ask yourself
do you want to be a [ __ ] commando
today you know when your bones ache
and you found all your injuries and you
just want to quit on life you need to
ask yourself you want to be a [ __ ]
commander then when it's cold outside
it's raining and you know the right
thing to do is to get up
and exercise your body because
you're this weapon that america needs
you need to ask yourself if you're going
to be a [ __ ] commando today
and i was 11.
can you imagine
the impact that meant
command or a life of discipline when i'm
so weak and being picked on
see i don't think you were weak though
because it would have broken a lot of
people yeah you weren't weak you were
just you didn't know how to take control
yet you didn't know how to set
boundaries you didn't you were you were
not weak and not not to disagree with
your life story forgive me but you know
that would have broken a lot a lot a lot
of people man and you know jordan
peterson has a great saying that only
the violent are capable of peace
because if you're not capable of
violence you're incapable of peace
you're obedient you're subservient only
people capable of violence can choose to
be peaceful
you know everybody else it's not your
choice
so i mean in that regard it sounds like
you know the light went off where you
were like i need to become capable of
violence in order to gain the respect i
need and then
you know scale it back from there and
know when to use it and when naughty the
um the light went off
when a year after my father left me my
biological father left man i haven't
heard from him and i was being spit on
picked on
i was um now indoctrinated into a very
strict military upbringing because my
stepfather was a drill sergeant special
forces
it's 4 30 in the morning i would raise
the flag put the hand over my heart
i would do physical training before i
even start
school dress code i was what i'm saying
is i had a hard time with the discipline
and my mother came to me with this box
and she said you know son this this is
from your father
and you know and i i sat the box across
the room because i i was so disappointed
my father could see i i didn't hear from
him so finally i had to curse open up
this box i opened up the box and inside
this box was four contents
it was these vhs tapes that were dubbed
right and uh i ran and they were written
in vietnamese i i didn't know what you
know how to read vietnamese that i just
randomly picked up tape i threw it in
the vcr
it was the art of budo
if you don't know what that means it's
the martial arts side being samurai
the way
bushido
you know i was uh very defeated at that
moment and then this
this image of samurai this image of a
higher
mobile way uh
more way of living a moral values
to to dedicate your life to being the
warrior to to help others compassion you
know that's the bushido code right
so if you asked me patrick that was my
escape education
bushido
a warrior's uh upbringing we uh in the
samurai culture that called bushi the
study of being a warrior samurai
so at 16 you know i i
tried out for uh
you know a lot of the intensive training
the physical training that i know i
needed for special ops
and at 18 there was no direct hire into
special forces back then so i went to
the uh 82nd paratroopers i went to the
long range reconnaissance uh
uh amphibious reconnaissance teams and
then i made to special forces at 21.
two were you uh what was the first fight
you ever got into like where you beat
somebody up how old were you in the
first first fight you got into
oh i was beaten almost every day in um
in
elementary school in junior high i
wouldn't say it was more me fighting it
was them beating me when did that stop
when was the first time where they said
you know what i just probably not a good
idea to mess with two anymore man this
guy i remember that i started studying
martial arts when i was eight more the
uh discipline my
stepfather was he taught me the green
beret side of
combatives you know special forces
hand-to-hand combat
so there was this bully picked on me uh
and i
smashed his nose in you know
unfortunately he shattered his whole
nose um
eight years old no i was thinking i was
at 12 at that time okay i had enough so
by middle school you were ready to yeah
i was that kid you know when you go back
uh when you're wall locker and you have
post stickers like [ __ ] and go back
home like those were normal for me
right and i got tired of it and i
smashed in this kid's face yeah and um
oh man um
i was in trouble you know not only in
school but at home because my father was
teaching me these moves and here i am uh
employing them in a um
a very lethal way because did this
happen consistently or no were you were
you the guy that got into a lot of
fights or no no okay you know i um i
believe in the martial arts i believe in
if we can not fight don't fight so here
here's the story of not fighting so
my father didn't want me to fight right
he said you're not doing it you're
you're gonna you're gonna go to school
you're gonna be this this
you know gifted kid ap classes you're
going to do this right i told you not to
fight back yeah wow yeah because so many
movies were killing moves
because you knew the moves but he said
didn't want you to even destroy these
is to
uh to blow out somebody's eardrums by
cupping your hands to put your fingers
through somebody's eyes to just shash
into smashing their face and nose to
break their neck if we need to
um but these are moves that were taught
to him in the special forces and moves
that was given to me but in a in a very
secret manner yeah this is not breaking
balsa wood to get your yellow belt type
of stuff exactly
is true actual pluto is true the art of
buddha which is the combat side of being
a lawyer so i knew all that and i was
being picked on as being you know but
this this is where uh strategy came to
play because i was a student of ninjutsu
and samurai and i was studying when i
say a student i would study right the
the history and the arts and and the
ninjas are always about what about
outsmarting your opponent right because
they were employees of spies
reconnaissance so uh i i realized that
and i knew the bully schedule so i would
write down his timeline his schedule and
i look at his pattern of life and then i
knew his pattern of life and his his
schedule so i avoid his pattern of life
in his schedule
now when you um
you seem to have been very very alone in
your upbringing a lot of the uh viet
community down south in my time biloxi
mississippi some other places out by you
know dallas they they come in in groups
there's entire families that come and
they resettle you know from the refugee
camps where were you and your mother and
your brothers you know alone in
fayetteville no so fayetteville i want
to say is a is a mixed town because of
the military uh population right so a
lot of military foreigners so i'm very
mixed town but when you're saying the
vietnamese refugees i wanted to bring
this because this is another incident
that led me to who i am today was when i
was 11 first my uncle right he gave me
that speech another later on that year
my mother would drive across town and
then we would drive hours
hours she would drive to to drop off
food to these refugees
right
and i i told my mother so i asked my mom
like mom why do you do this why do we
waste all day driving across town to
give food to people that don't even care
they didn't even say thank you
my mother she stopped the car she
grabbed me and she she said look at me
she said you know son
it doesn't matter conditions or
circumstances if we can we must help
others
and in doing so we create a better world
you see that's confucialism that's
confucius right if you want to make a
better world it starts with him
and um i realize that and i knew like
the the special forces
had the ability to enter countries in
the fritos oppressed and the freedom
slaves and to fight for the people that
were my family what's really very very
fascinating to me about your story is
the juxtaposition with socialism that
you talked about earlier you know
the ccp in particular uses those
confucian origins to spread socialism
they said socialism is just the logical
economic implementation of confucianism
and
you are in that upbringing in that
environment where you're getting picked
on constantly the the upper class or
reminding you of how poor you are you're
feeling
very very helpless in that moment you
are
ripe for the picking for you know
extremist communist socialist ideology
you are their their top target and yet
you
to from from what i know about you
you're a pretty staunch anti-socialist
how did those two things come about with
socialisms when imprisoned my family
socialism is what murdered my family
i saw the genocide i saw the
the um
depression
from it
so i felt that energy it's not like i'm
reading a socialist ideology i've seen
it firsthand i've seen it around the
world i've seen
uh communist countries
you know i've been to 27 countries
you know communism in uh was our primary
enemy when i first came in we would
study
the sounds of helicopters and vehicles
of russian
uh tanks
russian helicopters we would close their
eyes and and hear russian helicopters on
a uh on a headset and we have to write
down what we're hearing and the distance
we're hearing from and
and the directions coming from so what
i'm saying to you is we study russian
doctrine because that was our enemy
it's always been our enemy we took our
eyes off the ball
i have a question for you regarding
patriotism right so i i totally
understand why you would have no love
for communism or socialism that's
literally what
killed your family and friends back in
vietnam
but
to use gerard's example juxtapose that
with coming to america this capitalism
uh home of capitalism
and
there you are eight years old getting
spit on called the [ __ ] beat up
you know
left for dead
so to speak
where does the patriotism come from that
you say all right i gotta fight for this
country it's like you're almost like a
man without a home where it's like
you're getting kicked out of your
country you come to america they're
literally telling you [ __ ] go back home
how do you become a
american patriot like where does that
come from
i was raised by warriors
i was raised by green berets
i was raised by patriots
i was raised by my grandfather who
fought
in the second world war and
you know the korean wars i was raised by
my father who fought in wars and
defended our our countries and our
freedoms i had no freedom come in this
country so i know what it means to not
be an american
right i wasn't given
um
you know a status of freedom i didn't
have even a country so when people say
go back to your country we had no
country
we had nothing so
why the patriotism because america gave
me a home when no other country didn't
so no matter how unfairly or unjustly
you're being treated you still loved
america is that fair to say do you do
you believe that
one person as racist towards you
reflects all of americans
do you believe in you know because i
served in the united states army and i
felt racism all through all the way to
the top tier the national asset of
america
do you
stereotype everybody because of one or
two
you know so the thing is this i'm
stronger than hate
i said that when i was eight
so i'm stronger than racism i'm stronger
than oppression i'm stronger than all
these things
did you have friends in school that said
come on too like you're my guy man like
just let's forget about that [ __ ]
over there like let's hang out let's go
like whoa
i was ostracized i was did you have any
friends the kid that was poor that stink
that smelled like fish
i was that
was that i still make your blood boil
no
because it's through the struggles you
find your strength so i realized that
unless i faced at a young age i wouldn't
have the the strength i needed to fight
for the oppressed i wouldn't understand
what it means to be that
so when when when i go into a village in
africa or in the philippines and i'm
fighting in zamboanga and these these
children lost their freedoms i can
understand a deeper level
than anybody else
how do you feel
taking that to today
how do you feel when you see you know
somebody incredibly wealthy like jon
stewart somebody i'm a fan of as a
comedian do a segment on the problem
with freedom or you see
incredibly well-fed wealthy ivy league
students championing socialism and
telling people to give up their freedom
of speech you know you're coming from a
place of
of
like you said before this isn't reading
philosophy you're not reading das
capital you've lived it so now you see
these people and and do you pity them do
you say they just don't know what they
know or or what what are what are your
thoughts on on this moment
it it's hard to see america at this
moment because we're so divided in our
ideals and uh the greatest country
you know um
i mean any patriot loves our country
right we all love our country
um yeah it's it hurts me divided but the
thing that i realized is this after the
war
was um
you have to know what you can change and
what you can't and you have to put
you have to put focus on what you can
change and what you cannot
so if america is so divided i as a
patriot as i as an american as a refugee
that made it into this country
and you you tell me man what other
country can you come here as a refugee
and be who you are
to be an entrepreneur and to be who you
are to be this leader in america when
you came from absolutely nothing
you know i slept on the dirt floor
rats
in the jungle and here i am this
entrepreneur now a leader in america
where else
can a system a country allow you to do
something like that
to let me let me ask you this if we can
go back because i want to get into some
of your thoughts on current events right
now and what's going on but so you're at
uh uh you're at fort bragg
you you choose to go special ops 23
years you're in so i'm assuming first
three years you do boot camp ait all the
things you do three years later you join
special ops so kind of how it happened
you know i went to basic uh you know
airborne i went to ranger training you
know so all of the advanced infantry
training yeah and then when i went to
special operations and that's did you do
special forces or special forces okay
and what was your mo what were you in 18
delta i was 18 bravo what started 18 fox
and then zulu got it did you were you
part of special ops with delta or was it
special more special forces
i was in the unit for eight years
you weren't a unit for it yes i was a
direct support asset to the unit
conducting the low vis reconnaissance
so basically i was the guy who would go
around uh work with dcia yep the uh at
the embassies we will go and we'll find
fix and finish the enemy
abroad what were some places you were
deployed yemen
southern thailand libya
niger
i mean you name it i mean we
we were everywhere you know during the
global war what's the craziest situation
you were in when you were in the
military that you can talk about
you know every mission is crazy patrick
right
uh you know obviously the gun fights are
always crazy but that that gets played
out almost every day you know in in uh
in the war zone
um
i want to talk about like okay so libya
qaddafi dictator right so he brainwashed
his people you couldn't even have a
western education
and there was this uh
[Music]
we call them sources people that work
for the americans that provides
intelligence
and he was working for us and he was a
proud father
he had a beautiful daughter she was very
smart
and she wanted a western education
you know so he would secretly get her
these books and have a read
you know and then one day the government
came to their door and drug their family
out in the street
put them down in their knees
and
they burned out her eyes
so
those are some things that we see
overseas you know
that people never understand
um so those those are the crazy things
that we see is that people
get tortured you know in today's society
people think that
you know we live in america where
everything is good and danny
everything's nice but
in today's world it's still savage
you know and if you don't have no law
and order in government system that's
set in place like what our country is
which is the greatest country
then we will too
be that
so
you know patrick i have a lot you know i
just you know it's so there's so much
emotions tied to somebody's you know
when my friend got out he was in special
ops and and uh not only was he special
ops he was also a delta unit for
eight years same as you and he went all
over and
my orders at the time was to go to
vicenza italy i was going to go to seer
school
i was already aerosol i was going to
airborne i was going to go dli to
tighten up my language because i spoke
five languages at the time
and i was going to go vicenza and then
from there you know light it up and
eventually going to you know choose to
go delta i went a different direction he
chose that rod he took the orders he
went in
when he retired after 20 years i said
let's meet up we hadn't seen each other
for like 15 years i thought he was dead
quite frankly i was trying to find him
everywhere i couldn't find him anywhere
not on facebook not on social nowhere he
appeared out of nowhere on social we got
connected and this is my guy this is the
guy that you hung out with every day for
two and a half years so
i said let's meet up so we meet up in
madrid
let's go watch you know we'll go to el
clasico
ronaldo was playing messi i said let's
meet up in madrid he didn't come to the
game but he met me at madrid
i said how you doing
and uh
very traumatic this guy was in this kind
of a traumatic guy he was a fun guy to
be around he was not in a good place
at all for what i said what happened
what have you seen can't talk about it
he had a drink then he had a second
drink three drinks he still wouldn't
talk about it some of the stuff that he
had seen but he was very very emotional
he would call me regularly saying pat i
don't know how to deal with this stuff
right now it took about a couple years
for him to
disconnect from that life how long did
it take you after your 23 year stint
that you had to live a normal life i
know you're still married i think right
20 plus years you guys were married yeah
it's pretty crazy to know that you lived
that life and you're still married for
20 plus years
how long did it take you after that life
to actually accept the civilian life
three years that i realized i don't have
to have my my bags packed and watching
the news
three years
three years of me not having to watch
current events and and and worry about
me
being deployed um
six years
before i found calmness of the mind six
years do you ever uh
itch
the desire you know how athletes retire
they want to go back you know how the
movie hurt locker he got out he couldn't
wait to get back
these stories was like chris kyle i got
to get back man i don't feel like the
civilian life is for me and the wife is
trying to tell you listen relax let's
enjoy
let's have a life together do you have
that itch like dude i want to go to this
freaking place because i know i can
bring some value is that itch there to
want to get deployed and get into the
mix or no
i always want to help people
and i i guess that's why path is a ronin
now is i i help people
um my time overseas helping people
staying in villages and all that i just
can't physically do that anymore
you know but i always want to help
people
um was it hard let go of the gun fights
and all that adrenaline is
is very um
there's no drug out there
like the adrenaline like that at that
level of a gunfight right so people have
a hard time disconnecting
um for me i worked hard um after my uh
my time of service to disconnect and i
do it through meditation and everything
else so i i purposely
um walked down a path of peace
you know when i got out not a lot of
people do that no no especially not in
your world because it's typically
drugs alcohol you know some crazy [ __ ]
that they end up doing when they when
they've seen that kind of life because
as much as you're glad you're out
somehow your body is that's your norm
that's your normal life that you've had
so
it's very hard to adjust from that
pacing to
this thing being this slow it's going to
drive you insane most people it's going
to drive them yeah you know it's real
funny patrick when i got out i i went
into the entertainment kind of oh world
really they found me really fast because
you know i'm a knife i'm a martial
artist i'm a gunfighter so it appeals to
hollywood you know so they they reached
out to me they wanted me to be on shows
on call of duty now so it's really like
uh a different mindset now you know i
mean i have to let it go sometimes
you know like sometimes for you when i
walk in i'm like okay this is a pool
door it's a solid corridor this is my
extra rail this is how many piece i had
to let those things go
are you able to take orders from people
that are not you know i mean imagine
taking uh direction from somebody that's
like you know 35 years old 120 pounds
and they're they're telling you what to
do and you're just sitting there like
man i could i could take your eyeballs
with my pinky no i don't think that
would i don't think that when i look at
people he's asking it because he's
struggling
he wants to yeah that's not how much
that's not how my brain works you know
guys how my brain works how my brain
works it's 4 30 in the morning i'm i'm
embracing god i'm showing gratitude to
life and today
like that's that's who i am today you're
like you know i never wanted that to be
that violent you know in my career i did
it for compassion i did it to freed
enslaved
and as soon as that was over for me
what's my next purpose my next purpose
is to mold americans to to you know law
enforcement is having a hard time right
now
you know with their image and their
tactics and
and that's why i'm teaching i'm teaching
law-abiding citizens to protect
themselves you know across america
so along with that that i had to let go
of that hate
you can't be who you are if you hold on
to hate right i don't think it's about
holding on to hate i think it's maybe
more addiction to power when you're
talking about guys that come out and
they're getting violent it's because
they can because somebody tells them
something that they don't want to hear
and they're like you don't get to tell
me you're not you don't outrank me i'm
going to show you
20 years of imposing your will on other
people you don't just get to turn that
off no and you know like i say three
years you know i was i was talking one
of my friends is you know when you're in
the special forces when i kick open that
door when i come in i have
you're gonna feel an energy
right so
i don't want that energy when i live in
civilian life right so i i have to cut
it off
and a lot of guys can't cut it off when
you're there yeah so so uh ronan how did
that happen with call of duty i mean you
know how does it even feel knowing
you're in a video game oh man so you
know i uh at first i was in the history
channel when i was filming there so yeah
uh
yeah what's bill goldberg like
he's so cool he's one of my friends i i
go out goldberg goldberg the wrestler
yeah yeah so bill and i were the jew
we're friends
the third best jewish athlete of all
time behind sandy kofax and adam sosnick
there it is yeah wow
yeah so that was my first time being on
the set like literally that day was my
first rookie year yeah
that's day one
um that was the second season so we did
three seasons really popular uh it got
really so it was uh broadcasting like 12
different uh countries this is what show
knight knife or death beating the hell
out of ice with knives ropes don't stand
a chance yeah so you're a big dude man
the goldberg must be six six how big is
this guy he was 260 there
yeah height wise i mean that guy's not
so he's like six four okay he was a
defensive end in the nfl before he was a
wrestler that guy don't play
but he's still he's so intense you know
i want to bring you to this day so i'm
here right now he's intense
you're literally the most intense person
i've ever met in my life and you're
calling him intense so i had my nose and
i was seeing it dude it was like 115
degrees in that hangar because they had
these fire barrels but it's in the
middle of the summer in atlanta right so
i had these fire so i'm sitting there
and it gets hotter during the day people
don't know the lights that are on so
it's hotter and hotter and hotter bill
comes in with his shirt off his cowboy
boots
you know and he's like it's so [ __ ]
hot in there
and he goes i need a cooling tent and
this and that and i'm like i don't even
know where coolington is so dan he's a
typical hollywood star
love him then he looks at me and he was
reading his notes and he looks at me he
goes
are you [ __ ] meditating because i was
sitting there
like this and i say i'm slowing down my
heart rate not anymore bill ryan's
slowing down my heart rate because then
it it cools down my body so i won't you
know uh sweat
right
so here's bill trying to make he's so
funny though you know that was one of my
first days you tried to meditate you got
bill goldberg to try to meditate right
you're trying to he's pretty he's pretty
cool dude right so uh he has a spiritual
side of him what what you see he is high
energy
but getting back call of duty so we're
doing close quarters training in uh san
francisco right and uh infinity war they
follow us you know on social media on
youtube so i post where i am and i post
like what i'm doing right training and i
was training close quarters battle
and uh
if any ward
emails us and say hey can you fly out to
la you know so here we are we're toting
our guns our equipment can you pull that
up type in call of duty 2 lamb
and then we go out there
it was my wife and i and we're standing
out there and we met the president right
so first we met the teams and they're
broke demand they're so professional
they're broken up so creative and then
the president comes out and he was a fan
and he he said hey man big big fan thank
you for everything you do and he goes he
talked to us for a good three minutes
and he said how can i get you on the
game
you know
excuse me
he goes how can i get you in the game my
wife is standing there and she goes well
if you want ronan
okay what else and we run our own gear
yeah we design yeah and then she's like
well you know you want that then you
know he wears his own he goes okay done
deal is that your gear that's her
basically what they did was they plucked
me out he just threw me in the game
literally you know special force for
them all that right and i did the motion
capture
so you see there in motion capture in
the studios
with them
you know we uh we recently did motion
capture all the gun scenes and
everything uh with them so
it's it's been really uh
amazing journey and you know what what i
take from this
is that uh man you know a bunch of kids
are playing my character now
a bunch of kids but you know what
you know bruce lee when he was an actor
right
he used his platform to spread about
equality
right about martial arts educating
people and i do that the same you know
i'm not bruce lee obviously but i i use
my platform to to spread
the word about
compassion love you know um
leadership right so i use that i'm
giving the tools to all these youth
right they're such a moldable age right
now and they're playing my character so
why not give them a word where does the
character or your alter ego
ronan where does that come from because
that's
what is that the basis of that
so you know i i live the life of bushido
i live the life of the way the warrior
right so bushido in japanese is broken
down bull means to intercept the spirit
to go to war
she is the one who chooses to walk the
path the one who's strong enough to walk
the path the way warrior and dole is to
take your whole life experience
and to give back for the sake of
humanity
bushido
right so i walked the path of bushido so
let me explain what ronin means so
back in the frugal stating periods of
japan were staying appears japan you had
samurai who served the daimyos right so
if you were fired you become ronin the
masterless so it was very shameful this
honorable to be a ronan back in war
staying pierced japan but there were
ronins that were
you know famous like miyamoto musashi
the 47 ronins you know there were
stories of these ronins they were
amazing so where did ronin come from you
know i was uh
after i got out of the army i was
heavily addicted to painkillers
you know and patrick would tell you man
like that's a normal thing in in our
world you had a similar problem did you
not
no
okay
don't blame me
maybe it was something else then it
wasn't it wasn't painkillers yeah okay
but patrick would tell you like in this
special operations world we thought he
had that dude we mask our pain man
it's such a um
intense world you know that world
special operation swirl
you come back from a rotation a combat
rotation you can't even talk to anybody
about what happens you're driving
defensively on the road and you don't
even know why you're doing because your
brain is switching to that level
so i was really messed up right and i
got out
and i was sitting in the dark room one
day
defeated the feet of my wife was working
on the dinner i was defeated caught up
in pain killers wanted to quit
and the voice told me get up so i got up
i had this blanket and walked around the
dark house and somehow ended up in my
library and i opened up this bookcase
and i had books
from since i was
gosh i started reading since i was 11. i
had books all around the world too right
and somehow i just reached in i grabbed
the book didn't even look it was the
book of five rings by miyamoto musashi a
ronan
that was born in the late 1500s and died
in 1645 after writing a book of five
rings now i'm holding in my hand he
wrote it in the buddhist cave after
meditating for three years finding his
peace here i am holding this book in my
hands and the pastor said all your love
all your emotion everything exists
everything exists look nowhere else but
within
so it's a legendary book by the way it's
like a
you know art of war five rings
um
you know
40 loss of power i think talks about
five rings yeah it's it's a 33
strategies award book also spends a lot
of time talking about that fascinating
stuff would you mind if we get some of
your thoughts on what's going on today
i want to kind of hear your thoughts on
what's going on so
number one let's go to page five
shipping crisis in america
today
um so there's a lot of talk about
shipping crisis and people have
different opinions
on what's going on america isn't running
out of everything just because of a
supply chain crisis america's running
out of everything because americans are
buying so much stuff this is an insider
story and uh uh this story is coming
from warrens
that national retail federation's okay
americans aren't buying everything they
can get their hands on and they'd be
buying even more of it if it weren't for
those uh pesky supply chain snarls the
national federal national retail
federation said those shortages seem so
uh
uh uh uh you say that word right there
for ambiguous ambiguous ubiquitous
that the term everything shortage is now
being used uh
liberally to describe consumers
frustration as they try to get goods of
all sorts paper towels milk toys and
more to understand the situation
consider the country's inventory to
sales ratio this metrics tracked by the
u.s census bureau compares how much
stuff sellers have on hand on how much
stuff consumers are buying the ratio is
at a 10-year low which indicates that
we're low on stuff it's low because
sales have gone completely nuts in the
in the first nine months
of 2021 retail sales were up 14 and a
half percent over the same period in
2020 and today we have a hundred ships
waiting offshore at la porte wood cargo
which is an examiner story 23 of the
waiting ships are mega containers
meaning they are the largest shipping
vessels in the world that can hold more
than a hundred of more than ten thousand
twenty foot containers ships must abide
by a set of rules which uh when picking
up a spot such as standby ship lanes and
anchoring at two miles out from all this
other stuff so anyways we hear all these
stories about shipping shortages uh two
you have some experience with this what
do you think is really going on here is
it really a supply chain crisis are we
just buying too much stuff oh i i
definitely think it's both like you
we've been doing this to ourselves for
many years outsourcing right
manufacturing right bringing imports
instead of pushing out esports so we're
relying so much on other countries think
about what we're doing with with with
all the products you know uh
manufacturing china manufacturing in
south america all these are cheaper
labor right so uh businessmen is going
to want to go
and get so we've been doing this for
years growing a wealthy
uh
america right independent business
owners are getting more wealthy by
outsourcing to uh ford so we've been
doing this and this became a norm in
america we've been building this
infrastructure for years relying on
external imports china built that empire
off of slave labor for example exactly
so now with with us relying on other
countries uh with kovitt hitting right
covet obviously shut down the whole
world so now we're we're that backlog
what you're saying now patrick is do you
think that you know america overspending
yes i do think that too because we do
not okay
i feel
there's a percentage of america a large
percentage of america that does not
trust
the administration right now does not
trust the future of american our safety
of america so that's why they're going
to stock up they're going to stock up on
on water they're going to stock up
what's causing the lack of trust though
what is causing the lack of trust
i hear many different things i'm curious
what you think well you know like uh how
you know
deceitful the media is on certain things
like they're saying there's no shortage
but then we go into a grocery store
they're saying there's no shortage but
then it takes us forever to to buy
something online getting a stake these
days right so what i'm saying to you
there is a shortage and um
you know i i feel like the
administration too is kind of playing it
off
as in you know
um i mean we we heard about you know the
imports of goods and uh
you know they they made a common
administration man a comment about the
uh what the reclining chairs oh you
won't have a dishwasher
right so they're they're kind of like uh
pushing that off but america is kind of
overspinning
they're being condescending about it a
little bit right right so but but that's
why americans overspending because they
do not trust the media but there's also
a lie too because of if if the reason
why there aren't things to buy is
because we're buying so much stuff then
why isn't the economy booming
economy's tanking
so we're overspending why is the economy
tanking i feel economy is tanking
because we're mass reducing the american
dollar right so inflation's going
through the roof right now unemployment
is going through the roof you know i
mean um uh we're supporting the
non-working class so that's not going to
bring back our it's not going to bring
back our economy
do you guys see the county in the the uh
central coast county in california can
you pull that up central coast county
california gas prices i posted this
yesterday
abc eyewitness news kyle texas to you
california gas prices in this county hit
no this is not an exaggeration
7.59 cents a gallon
7.59 a gallon premium is nearly 850. i
predicted ten dollar gas prices are
coming i'm two dollars away at that time
for anybody that just bought a ferrari
premiums through the roof
i walked here this morning it took me
seven hours i was thinking about getting
a car but not anymore well that's
definitely not gonna happen well you
brought there's two sides to this
because i i you know you brought up the
supply chain issue we talked about that
on the last podcast phil heath who i
believe you know
uh he said his mom worked in the supply
chain he had a good personal story but i
also think there's another side to this
which you
touched on is that in america we buy a
lot of [ __ ]
like a lot of [ __ ]
and you said that some of the
happiest people you've ever seen in your
day have just been the poorest people
that didn't have a lot of stuff going on
their life and i think that you know
what i've seen is that americans
consume a lot of stuff i'm not saying
i'm a minimalist but i i definitely
gravitate towards being a minimalist not
needing the fancy stuff
to fulfill your life like it's a it's a
it's actually a scientifically proven to
be a sugar high oh i want to get this i
want to get this and three days later
you know you're super super excited to
get a new pair of shoes or a new bag or
new whatever and three days later
scientifically your um emotions or
morphines that's what i mean it's like
we look at the like bushido right
musashi said we look at the externals to
to allow us to feel something internally
right and wealth is one of them right uh
materialistic items is another one look
that's an american thing exactly okay
that's the american thing we're the
credit card we're not gonna change that
okay well this we're not i don't know if
we're gonna change the entire culture
but this is where you have to look
inside
yourself and look in the mirror and say
do i really need this is buying more
stuff
really what i'm looking for in life i
get it people need the basics people
need milk people need you know gas in
this case
all the consumerism but also the
shortages it's because the gas prices
are going through the roof yeah the
shortage on truck workers and the
mandates yeah so i i feel like that's
shorting that's closing down the supply
chain as well these are two different
issues here what should your church say
okay so let's just say what you're
saying is save that money fine well i'm
just saying that there's a flip side to
the supply chain stuff it's that how
much stuff do you need we're talking
about they're cancelling christmas but
so you're not getting 20 christmas
presents
that's a question to say how rich is
good how rich is rich like so so
if you if you live in america the reason
why you love america is because a person
has a freedom to choose okay
america was founded on four different
things freedom to choose freedom to
freedom to buy freedom to sell freedom
to fail freedom to try buy sell try fail
it's up to you go for it's capitalism do
what you got to do you want to buy it
buy it you don't want to buy it don't
buy it it's totally up to you
this is not a
philosophical conversation here about
this this is about why the hell do we
have the shortages one is saying we're
buying too much the other is saying oh
it's because
100 ships are sitting out there we can't
get it up people don't want to come in
here and work and take that stuff off
ten thousand containers that you're
talking about the biggest one they got
23 these ships are the biggest ships you
know you got jen sackey uh uh uh
who comes out yesterday saying when
asked about biden's supply chain crisis
sack he cracks a joke at the expense of
americans this is a post-millennial
story she says it was a cl it was clear
march of 2020 when covert hit that the
supply chain across the world had been
disrupted even as a sort of work to
fight back against covet proceeded
people it was crystal clear that the
that things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and furniture and treadmills delivered
on time not to mention all sorts of
other things so why did
the tragedy of the treadmills that's
delayed
she talks about him joking about it
during the pandemic many gyms were
closed et cetera et cetera so
you know this is about this christmas
people are not going to get stuff on
time and they're preparing everybody
don't expect your gifts to show up on
time
why is this happening america is not
going to change their habits overnight
that takes a generation or two to do but
this concern here you got a capitalistic
society who's accustomed to getting
products being delivered on time now
they're not yeah this isn't philosophy
this is management you know
philosophically you want to talk about
minimalism it's a different conversation
i agree yeah like this is you know the
this is just america this is a global
supply issue it's not like this is
immune to america yeah only in america
it's crazy it's almost like the entire
world
i know it's crazy it's almost like will
you write nothing and behave right
because the entire world's been dealing
with a pandemic
but yeah poorly too
so listen the the la la in particular
there's the regulations are what are
shutting down the la right now it's it's
it's government that's causing a
six-month backlog it's not the pandemic
it's the government response to the
pandemic it's also a lack of workers we
discuss which is which is due to the
government response to the pandemic
you know this is it's it's it's very
very very clear there's not a backlog in
jacksonville right now one of the
biggest ports on the east coast is there
a six-month backlog of the is the supply
chain broken and in the you're saying
this is on gavin newsom
it's on gavin newsom okay it's on bill
de blasio it's on andrew cuomo it's on
it's on people that aren't controlled
how are they how's new york affecting
l.a
de blasio
this is a literal nationwide logistics
problem that way we just said it was
just
jacksonville the problem jacksonville is
fine you can you can look at where the
backlog is there's a backlog in new york
harbor there's a backlog in elizabeth
there's a backlog the the la backlog is
as9 it's like six months behind right
now it's actually cheaper for a lot of
these ships to redirect from the pacific
go through the freaking panama canal and
then come to the east coast they will on
they will unload quicker than waiting in
port in l.a
you know so
freedom to try freedom to try man listen
this this this is logistics
just this morning there's a guy i had
breakfast with at my uh at my condo man
the guy sells pepperidge farm cookies
it's incredible how much money there is
in cookies man
398 was where the cookies started this
year they're up to 417. he sells them
wholesale he said they'll be five
dollars by the end by the end of the
year i mean that doesn't seem like much
that's a 33 increase in one year just
off of shipping
33 on cookies what what's milk what's
things that need to be refrigerated
cookies can stay on the shelf for two
years what are things that are
perishable i mean it's going to go
through the roof man we've only just
begun to feel the pain
look i i'm with you clearly we need our
stuff in america especially if it's
staple industry but we talked about it
takes generations to fix
well i'll flip it on you there's
somebody named marie kondo you know who
that is
who basically said
you know goes to people's houses and
says does this spark joy to you
and if not get out get rid of it sure no
matter what's going on with supply chain
and macroeconomics and tariffs or
whatever at the end of the day this
comes down to how many [ __ ] cookies
do you actually need okay how much extra
stuff do you need i got i get
staphylococcus i'll put you on friday
i'll put you on front street then why do
you live in boca raton for three times
the amount of money it would cost you to
go live out in coral springs right like
you can go we can go west in the swamps
and live for five hundred dollars if
it's about efficiency yeah how can we
don't live out there you could have like
where i live yeah that's your choice
that would be close okay
the money to do it that would be seen as
excessive that would
it's excessive as compared to buying a
single wide out in the swamps right like
i mean if everything is about efficiency
if everything if materials yeah but if
the world crumbled
and i had to go live in a smaller place
i didn't have any money i'd still be
happy
like i get it like supply like i'm not
like oh my god i have to go and move
into a smaller unit buddy i lived in a
little
shack in dallas
just to be a minimalist well you loved
it not really
but i did it because i wanted to be a
part of valuetainment and that's what i
was willing to do to go through the
struggle in this case i mean not that
big of a deal but that's what i was
willing to do
but
a part of me i understand our supply
chain i get it but cry me a river if
your cookies are a dollar or more bro
let me let me ask you a question kai
pull up a larger pull up the top 10
ports in the u.s pull up the top 10
ports in u.s
top 10 ports in the u.s yeah
so let's go through so number one is
what you got la is one okay long okay
got it so hang on let me see the numbers
right there
seventy five hundred acres going to the
teams of vessels 178 ml revenues tons
276 billion dollars of value
uh leading trading partners china hong
kong japan south korea 1.6 million
they're okay keep going to the next one
it's our gate to the west yep long beach
long beach's next uh
uh
370 okay go to next new york and new
jersey is third
got it that's also china india germany
then it's georgia port savannah and
brusnick okay well just so you know guys
the number three new york and new jersey
that's actually three separate ports
there's port newark port elizabeth and
then there's port of manhattan okay then
the new york naval lard which is
actually in brooklyn got it so you got
georgia ports
seattle tacoma port so georgia gets uh
automobiles heavy machinery agriculture
products uh deep water terminals gardens
okay got it so that's coming from where
samantha's okay so then we have seattle
tacoma ports uh oil seats grains
machinery computers then we got six uh
port metro vancouver go to the next one
basically seattle yep virginia is next
then we have houston
is eighth
go to nine and ten south carolina
oakland oakland is willing to help l.a
by the way because right now apparently
oakland is not that busy so oakland's
sending their workers right now to l.a
to help out
with the shortage that's going on yeah
so listen there's two conversations here
with what you're saying versus what's
going on one
the issue at hand is what
we we have all these ships and they're
waiting and we're going to get that car
go out because people are running
businesses and if they don't get it and
some of the stuff that we talk about
sits there you may not even be
perishable can you sell it can you not
sell it that's a big problem right
two is a mindset about saving money
which that goes to conversation of
america being one of the worst savers in
the world well you know we're
overspenders we're constantly financing
everything which i don't uh disagree
there either we went one time to uh i
was at the an island
i don't know where this was barbados i
think i was at so the driver is taking
me
and uh we got 40 people in this bus he's
driving me i said so what do you do for
a living he says i'm the mayor
i said
yo they call you to me that's your
nickname he says no i'm the mayor
i said i'm serious he says i'm the mayor
of this town you're not the mayor this
time it's not to google me you guys
that's because i'm like sitting i'm like
come on bro you i said let me see your
license as a driver he gives me a lot i
google i'm like mayor of this city are
you the freaking mayor something mario
that's freaking sick good for you mayor
so we're driving we're having a good
time he's telling these stories i said
so tell me how economy works here if you
want to buy a house he says you see that
house right there that was my house
i said what'd you pay for that he said i
paid 80 000 for that house some small
number not a big number i said so when
he when it comes down to financing how
do you finance that thing he says oh
there's one thing we don't do we don't
do financing here i said how do you buy
that house he says you have to have cash
if you don't have cash you don't buy
that house what city is this this is
barbados some weird place i was out with
like dave ramsey fantasyland yeah but so
so i said that jen would remember this
so i said okay so i said so you need to
tell me anybody that buys a house or
buys cash who says anybody that buys a
house here you buy cash if you rent you
rent if you buy you buy so
that's the extreme of the complete
opposite side you have to have you want
to buy a million dollar house you got to
buy cash you want to buy six hundred
thousand dollar house you got to buy
cash okay so now you're not happy about
that part because to you it's like wait
a minute we need financing right well
to that country
financing and being able to go finance
the million-dollar loan and only put ten
percent down which is a hundred grand
you live in a million dollar home or
you're financing nine hundred thousand
dollars making a fifty two hundred
dollar mortgage payment per month you're
being a little aggressive i think that
part needs to be a balance when the no
income no asset loans we had and people
were financing 100 we financed 98
that was aggressive so i'm kind of with
you on a little bit more of putting up
cash to buy a house a little bit more of
less credit cards everything being debt
more buying stuff that you can afford
with your cash but at the same time
that's philosophy this is reality that's
going on today and they got to address
this they don't have a lot of time to
address this
that's a long-term fix we need a quick
short term fix right now being positive
don't you think that's something that
will get fixed over time i get it it's
an issue right now today but don't you
think they're active i'm not even being
political here don't you think that the
people in charge are actually trying to
figure it out i don't know if that's
true you think they're trying to
purposely sabotage it part of the
buildback better agenda is yeah there
there's there's some odd there's so they
want sabotage no yes
i'll just i'll just say yes who wants it
i think there's a global community i
think that there is a push so we
minimize our our our wealth in america
it's a wealth decision i don't disagree
with it right so if they're able to
control the supply chain we can't buy
and continue you know uh and they're
trying to save the the earth right with
the uh climate change by keeping these
ships out that burn billions of gallons
of diesel well not making not running
these factories to to keep on producing
our materialistic goods right i think
that there's a lot of a lot of what
we've dealt with in the pandemic is some
sort of long play into
climate change agenda well i want to
talk about this because my grandfather
right from world war ii
so
he always told me hey you can't buy you
can't buy it unless you could pay cash
for like that kind of attitude so where
did that mindset change because if you
look at the americans that came out of
the depression down there that they grew
up in that area they're all about
minimal right living so i think that
once america goes through this just just
a tip of iceberg we're going to go back
to that same methodology i can actually
answer that question when it changed
1978 the community reinvestment act
fannie mae freddie mac started student
loans government-backed student loans
government-backed housing
that's what started the free credit
spigot and it's only gotten worse from
there all right and credit cards that
came before that well diners cars diners
clubs all diners clubs exactly but you
had to what you had to do to get a
credit card back in the day was insane
the credit you want to talk about income
inequality in the world
credit score you know nobody ever talks
about this ever you've never seen
anybody march against credit right isn't
that crazy nobody's ever marched against
visa nobody's ever marched against
mastercard there's never been a occupy
discover
credit score is the largest wealth
disparity in the world the wealthier you
are the more access to funds you have if
you're if you're not wealthy or if
you've struggled and you need the money
they won't give it to you but you know
listen part of that also it's really
really genius it's really genius why
they went to education first especially
when you look at the fact that they got
rid of
uh you know like scores to get into
higher education now there's no testing
in a lot of high schools they're getting
rid of the s.a.t
higher education
is not about intellect anymore it's 100
about obedience and the longer you go in
education
the more you're willing to put up with
though it's more of an obedience test if
you get your phd with a state school you
may not have ever been in the top
echelon of your class you just stayed in
school now think of the brilliance of
that the brilliance of having people
literally pay to do work instead of
getting paid to do work for 10 years and
our society looks at them as if they're
the valiant our society looks at a
trucker a cdl about to make 250 grand
this year as if he gave up on life he
looks at somebody that enlisted in the
military as like last ditch right but
somebody that doesn't earn anything that
pays money to do work there's somebody
noble they get a name they're a doctor
they're a people well there's a flip
side to the story is that they actually
have to enter the working world at age
35 and then they get paid hopefully a
quarter million dollars half a million
dollars how's that working out because
people with masters and basket weaving
well obviously some people don't think
ahead of the roi of what you're going to
go to school for no clearly but there's
there's i believe there's a longer
strategy i think there's two things i
think there's two things i think there's
those
who maybe are uh evil
motivations that they have
let's just say there's a group like that
i think it's a very small community i
don't think that's big of a community as
a small community but they've got a lot
of power yeah you know i'm not
disagreeing i'm just telling you it's a
very small community that
is actually trying to do that to ruin
the western westernized philosophy
capitalism the rich all that other stuff
i think there's a flip side of it where
sometimes you do something in your life
and you didn't count all the
possibilities of negative things that
could happen to you and you're going to
pay some consequence suffer some
consequences and that's what's happening
right now today's a byproduct of bad
policies today's a bad bad uh byproduct
of uh
you know falling for the trap of let's
keep giving people free money today's a
byproduct of getting people not to go to
work and say no they need three more
months they need six more months keep
sending them money we're talking we're
talking about this right now and our
transportation czar is at home
yeah two two month uh uh
paternity leave two month paternity
leave uh which which
anyways two month paternity leave uh is
what they're going through while we just
had a baby did you take maternity leave
then the day i had it i was working so
but that's a different story i don't
have the luxury of being an educated
smart guy like pete you know i i don't
have the fancy degree yeah it's very
exciting i don't have that luxury
anyways going back to it byproduct bad
policies manipulators be on closed doors
sure small community bad policies would
produce this kind of a uh environment
that we currently have i don't know i
don't hate the manipulators pad i gotta
be honest that's their job that's what
they want to do right this is they want
to take over the world they want fair
okay that's what they want what i
who i actually hates a strong word who i
who i who i really blame
i blame the useful idiot i blame the
person that goes along with the
manipulators because they just want to
fit in they don't actually look into
anything they don't they don't look at
anything other than a completely
superficial understanding of what's
happening and they want to tweet
something so their favorite celebrity
retweets them they want they want to put
social pressure on a nurse that she has
to choose a single mother nurse has to
choose between putting something in her
body that she doesn't want or losing her
job and not being able to feed her kid
the people that are pressuring her
right into doing the quote unquote right
thing those are the people i can't stand
not the manipulators at the top because
you're right it's very very very few of
them but they they they manipulate the
masses
let's talk about let's talk about that
what just happened right now with the
potential exodus
of navy seals uh brings backlash i want
to read this to you especially you being
in that world yourself and want to get
your thoughts on this so
uh potential exodus of navy seals brings
backlash on vaccine mandates this is a
center square story defense secretary
lloyd austin announced in august that
with biden's approval that all u.s
service members must receive a covet-19
vaccine shot the decision came after the
fisa vaccine received full approval from
the u.s fda that mandate though leaves
many u.s troops facing a tough personal
decision it has been reported that
hundreds of navy seals have been told
they will not be deployed if they will
not receive the vaccine and will no
longer be able to serve as the navy seal
we generally have about 2 500 navy seals
said robert o'neill a former u.s navy
seal who claims to have killed the osama
bin laden
it takes time to get to certain levels
hundreds are leaving because of this
nonsense and you said this is happening
right now with
swat as well what are your thoughts
about this too
i mean the military unfortunately when
you started donna line your your uncle
sam's right so you're going to have to
listen to the orders of your superior
officers and these superior officers
that you're serving under is going to
listen to
the orders that they're the four star
generals there underneath the
politicians
so we don't have those luxuries in in um
in the military but for
for the special operations guys to be
mandated look guys it takes it takes a
lot of money to train one of us you know
for me they spent over a million dollars
train one of us and our experience level
it takes a long time to grow one of us
you know it's not like you graduate the
training and you get to the teams you're
proficient right
you get to the teams eight years into
the teams maybe you're proficient
right and you get more training as you
go so what i'm saying to you if these
are senior members
of the navy of the teams and when i say
navy seals this is socom special
operations command all together right so
they're mandating all these uh mandates
that you're gonna have to get the
vaccination but
guys are getting out
there um
they're not re-enlisting they're getting
out they're they're turning in their
paperwork they're getting this honorable
discharge whatever are you hearing these
stories because is it is it just a
couple guys writing about it are you
hearing about this actually taking place
right now where guys are leaving oh i
know some guys are doing it and i i'm
into that world you know and not and not
just the military i cross train i teach
swat teams i teach you know major police
departments all through the united
states i've been doing for six years
and they too are getting out these major
cities like
come on chicago one of the danger cities
in the united states i have uh some some
friends
um that are getting out they're taking
unpaid leave because they're they're not
going to do this and they're all leaving
because they don't want to take the job
they don't want to take the job and it
boils down to this guys
we don't they don't trust the
administration yeah you know i mean like
if if if there's another maybe
administration that's you know not so
deceiving maybe to their people
right think about afghanistan think
about all the borders all this stuff
right
right so many fronts that we're looking
at lies
and then you know
uh making fun of you know our supply
chain just blowing it off so that's why
they're building this
uh
group of on the americans that don't
trust the administration
well you told the story i think you said
it on rogan where when you joined the
army like you had no choice like you
went in 11 shots yeah they got your gun
yeah so but you didn't have a choice in
that manner no right no choice so
how does it work in the military or the
navy seals or in the army that
at some point you do get a choice
okay you don't get it so you have to do
it that's why they're getting that's why
you know um some of them are getting
disarmed with discharge they're they're
not being they're being punished that's
the part that's they're being punished
dishonorable that's like you're getting
fired like you're fired that's like
don't want as many
navy seals as possible
were you do we want them
you want as many warriors protecting our
country right
unless you don't want unless you're not
actually trying to protect the country
and you want some highly trained
individuals protecting our countries in
an unconventional war that's highly
trained in unconventional war so what
i'm saying is
dude we fought these wars overseas to
protect our homeland you know don't let
them throw the mask on and say oh we
were there to kill this guy yeah that
was a mission but we were there to
stabilize the region because that is a
natural resources that's why everybody's
trying to flock to the middle east to
control it because
he who controls the middle east control
the natural
resources yeah will become a superpower
yeah
the gate the gateway to the east what
were your thoughts on obviously the the
exit
in itself was the disaster leaving
afghanistan look but getting out look i
thought i'm not going to lie that you
know afghanistan was a long drawn-out
war america we dumped trillions
trillions of dollars and just just not
if afghanistan but iraq the philippines
the war in africa the war in the middle
you know i mean
you guys are not hearing the wars or
were fighting these secret wars right so
imagine that being dumped so we needed
to get out there but man any any
military guy would tell you there's a
plan withdrawal even if an ambush a raid
anything so simplistic like that but
imagine you've been fighting a war for
20 years we own that region
we militarily own that region and when
we started collapsing our forces in did
you know that the taliban took
90 percent of that country already when
they are getting the intelligence and
then they're saying oh it won't collapse
they already knew it's going to collapse
who do you put that on meaning
is it the generals is it actually biden
was it the the agreement that trump did
with the taliban you know
i want to let you know how the the the
rank structure works
right the president is the where the
buck stops but he has his military
advisers the military advisors advise
him on the tactics and the strategy on
how to withdraw it's up to the president
he will listen to it
you know so
i wasn't there i don't know what
conversations are being held but i'm
telling you when i saw how things unfold
on i don't know on on a public
television right i could tell you i can
war game it from there you should have
closed down all the air bases and go
down condensing only one air base we had
bagram we have all these other air bases
why are you gonna why are you going to
condense all your forces uh in one area
we know that they the taliban going can
control that area so what i'm saying to
you is there was a strategy just like a
strategy in war and withdrawal
there was no strategy on this withdrawal
and we lost our footing in one of the
most important regions in the world for
america for not only our safety but for
the growth of america
right economically
we did we we left it and then now we're
legitimizing a a uh the terrorist
organization we're about to finance them
we're gonna finance we're in the
gymnasium we're allowing them to enter
our country
you know so for me look i'm not a
politician man do you feel betrayed at
all as a as a service member
when you leave our troops
when you leave our troops to die when
you um
you know gosh man i've been in these
countries i've worked as singletons
you know i couldn't imagine being left
overseas serving my country under the
orders that you gave me
you're going to leave us and that's not
the first time this administration did
we did in libya
when when the annex got attacked and the
seals and the cia guys got drug out in
the streets we left the obama
administration yeah right we left them
right hillary
we left them so this administration is
showing that kind of same
lack of support for our our military who
who's ordered to go and fight
for the home for the safety of our
homeland
and what about the border patrol whose
order to protect our borders is now
being scrutinized
right judged off of a photo
off of
off of racism everything is racism
they're going to throw it in your face
you know you got to look at the bigger
picture here
right the bigger picture safety of our
country and the growth of our our
country and how are we going to sustain
you know
to be a superpower because i tell you
man
there's a lot of countries in this world
that wants to take us down
and our military is the only one that's
fighting overseas to safeguard our our
country and that too
you know is is being taken away to who
would you put out the top when he said
there's a lot of countries that want to
take us down who's at the top is china
at the top sean has always been at the
top patrick has always been at the top
yeah china china
you know people say do you think we're
going to go toward
you always said that to me
and said you know first of all
what does modern day warfare look like
to you
do you think it's propaganda yes do you
think that cyber warfare yes do you
think is uh manipulation social media
yes currency
economy
so we're already at war
all right
so don't don't judge war as troops on
the ground right hot war
right so once you own infrastructure you
own supplies and everything how can we
even go to war we can't even
we can't even fill up our tanks in in
jets because we're buying
our our gases and oil from
where middle east our enemies
we're we're making our enemies stronger
it's what we're doing and us losing
afghanistan and now china moving in
you don't think they have the the energy
supply it needs in northern afghanistan
supply their china
there's interest there
and they'll go to war for it
and let me ask you this so taiwan
that's our allies right so we we we left
our allies in afghanistan right we left
india now surrounded geographically by
the middle east now they're in the state
of deficit
right so now
who's going to protect you know who's
going to take our borders now because we
don't have eyes and ears in the middle
east anymore
you know afghanistan was a hub that we
use to get eyes and ears into to middle
east so we can flex where we needed to
that we can control the region stabilize
the region now you have a country that's
ran by terrorists
and it's known
to train terrorists in that that country
and now they're the richest
probably one of the richest countries
kai can you there's two things i want to
get a feedback from you on that was
powerful on the exchange there um
one with the time that we have left we
got 18 minutes left i want to get your
thoughts on
very wise to stelter we'll cover that i
want to talk about the re-education
camps and then there's a story that just
came up about uh joe manchin i don't
know if you saw joe manchin's story that
came up colin powell we'll address that
before we wrap up uh matter of fact
let's just do colin powell right now
uh page eight and then i'll go to the
other two stories um
colin powell first black u.s secretary
of state dies of cover 19 implications
amit cancer battle this is a cnn story
and he was fully vaccinated
first black u.s secretary leadership and
several republican administrations
helped shape american foreign policies
in the last years of the 20th century in
the early years of 21st century as that
complications of cove it was 84 years
old
and donald trump wrote to his supporters
wonderful to see colin powell who made
big mistakes on iraq and famously
so-called weapons of mass destruction be
treated in death so beautifully by the
fake news media hope that happens to me
someday he was a classic rhino
uh if even that always being the first
to attack other republicans he made
plenty of mistakes but anyway may he
rest in peace and president bush said he
was a great public servant starting with
his time as a soldier during vietnam he
was
such a favorite of presidents that he
earned the presidential medal of freedom
twice
two thoughts
uh what a great general we're a great
american at least he served his country
he rose up to be amazing general i
didn't serve underneath him i was in
high school i read books on
you know the the leadership uh that he
gave to our armed forces so i think he's
a great american what i think about
trump's statement
you know man politics is ugly
it's so ugly and um unfortunately some
people can't control
um
you know their emotions online but do i
support that statement
no i don't obviously i don't support i
love i love what colin powell did for
our country and i don't support that
statement but i will tell you that um
wars are very political
and lies and deceptions are made for
for to employ soldiers overseas
so
what i'm saying is politics can get ugly
but i do not support that
that message that trump said to the
general
adam
yeah i think uh colin powell is one of
those people whether you're on the left
or the right i i'm sure that there's
going to be people that disagree but you
look at him and just say wow like what a
what an admirable man
sure he didn't get everything right
and i know that towards the end he
definitely didn't align himself with the
republican party especially trump so
shocker alert
trump's talking crap about a
dead general
i i don't think anyone didn't see that
one coming but as an american
i think you can always look at colin
powell and say that's
that's what america is about he you know
came from a family of immigrants like
yourself like yourself
served in the in the army um
medal of presidential medal of freedom
twice
uh and may he rest in peace
yeah i don't think a lot of people know
his story did he know you talked about
dealing with your racism
nobody talked to him at west point for
four years
he was in west point nobody spoke to him
for four years
not a word not a single word until his
graduation
he didn't quit
he didn't he didn't turn coat he didn't
say screw this i would have been out
listen to hell with this
nobody spoke to the man
they didn't look at him for his first
year and he stuck through it i had lunch
with him once an incredibly powerful
powerful powerful figure disagreed with
with foreign policy i hate the bush
doctrine i don't think we should have
been in these places i think we're just
now seeing the fallout of the bush
doctrine i think it was a you know a
post-cold war
trying to donald rumsfeld and dick
cheney i can write a whole book on how
these these guys were evil in my eyes
and and i think h.l mankind said that
war is the logical conclusion of
politics and guys like cheney and
rumsfeld never had to go overseas but
they sent a lot of people over there and
i can't stand that um colin powell said
to me you know i met him i was playing
with the newark bears at the end of my
my only career and he goes uh
you know
when you're when your career is done you
should you should go into the to the
service and i was like man i don't know
if that's what i'm doing he goes that's
a shame we could use guys like you and
that was a really really powerful thing
i i it's to this day my biggest single
regret is that when baseball was all
ready to go immediately into the service
how old are you right now i'm 35. it's
not too late
i got three years
i don't know if i can run the miles
though
that would be that would be the struggle
but hey look they keep uh they keep
lowering the the standards i don't know
you know maybe i can identify as a as a
tree and not have to run at all i don't
know we'll see what happens
made the man rest in peace
uh and ever a chance to meet with him or
speak with them or have any interactions
with him and real quick pat before we
move on this should put to rest that
whole conversation that we had three
podcasts ago about desantis running or
not
if it it that that's not presidential
you know to to attack a guy who served
his country not a fan of that i don't
know why i mean that's i don't know what
that is
is like the least breaking news ever
this is
i'm not a fan of that but at the flip
side he said he's right politics is ugly
and dirty
you know god
when trump dies what do you think the
left's going to say when he dies
what do you think about what are an
admirable man yeah okay so when you when
that's he's not doing anything to change
it yeah no he's not doing anything to
change it but at the same time like this
comment mccain comment these are not
comments that are
what part of that comment gets support
though yeah like if you're trying to
flip anybody okay tell me how that
flipped anybody it's too petty they said
there's two perfect people right there's
two people like
minus a handful of people but the unborn
and the dead man just leave those two
alone it's dead they can't do nothing
they can't argue with you the argument
is over with move on so anyways it is
what it is may the man rest in peace
let's go to the final couple stories
that we have here uh america's
re-education camps this is a real clear
policy story we rightly criticize and
condemn china for sending more than one
million
yogurts muslims to
educate re-education camps but we have
our own milder version of re-education
camps that indoctrinate all for a
supposed good evolved cause we call our
re-education camps public schools okay
uh here's one example of it for evanston
right outside of chicago of what first
and second graders are now taught in
school this is not a one-off or a rogue
teacher this is the curriculum endorsed
by the superintendent and school board
this is curriculum this is the
curriculum for teaching seven-year-olds
it covers more than seven thousand
kitten gardeners through eighth grade
attending 15 school when at what
evanston and school across the country
are doing is unequivocally misguided it
is dangerous it is divisive it hinders
not help
uh inclusion healing progress community
and support what what do you say about
these re-education camps you had some
thoughts yesterday i'd love the audience
to hear it
you know guys look you know i
i know about the re-education camps
right my uncles was part of the
re-education camps i interviewed my
uncle growing up
um
it's about changing your mind
right it's about brainwashing you to a
whatever
ideology they're trying to
so
yes i do believe in the re-education
camps is our schools right they're
targeting our youth and they're
targeting our youth with uh the critical
race theories right um blaming a certain
race for for everything what you think
is going to happen man
what do you think when these kids grow
up what do you think you think it's
going to be a more racist world or you
think it's going to be a more civilized
world when we're introducing critical
race theories into
you know education well critical theory
comes from the frankfurt school it's
it's marxist in its origins and it's
meant to be divisive right it's it's an
actual you talked about modern warfare
this is psychological warfare this is
propaganda this is indoctrinating an
entire generation to believing that
there are good and evil based on
immutable characteristics things that
you cannot change about yourself you
were born as one of the good guys or
you're born one of the bad guys and the
only way to help the good guys if you're
a bad guy is to completely seed any
personal agency yeah so
um anybody who doesn't know about the
frankfurt school anybody that doesn't
know about critical race theory i i
really really really encourage you to
start reading up as much as you possibly
can and if you want to see what
indoctrination looks like uh look up um
what was it kai i sent you my china my
life as a communist party member i can't
it's from five years ago i can't believe
this is up uh there's two different
videos it's my life as a communist party
member look at like two minutes in
and then the other one is uh i don't
want free media and it's actual chinese
communist members talking about why you
don't need free media and you know why
life without free thought is actually
beneficial to the to the collective it's
fascinating fascinating to watch if you
guys have ever seen this stuff um
and and it's
it isn't it interesting though that they
want public school in our country that
they want public school to essentially
extend into people's mid-20s now
public school free college free free
community college so four years let's
talk about those free colleges china
funds our major universities they've
been doing this for a while yeah so
along with them funding our major
universities don't you think they inject
an idea into these
universities with the professors
because they're funding it right so
they're they're funding the curriculum
so they have a say in this so think
about it like
70s right so let's say the the uh the
post-vietnam war hippie era right think
about that so now they're injecting a
communist ideology where where are these
youth now there are politicians there
are leaders in america john kerry right
so now they have this communist ideology
who has embedded them in college now
we're just embedding in in in elementary
school
at a at a very vulnerable state in their
subconscious mind because they're going
to take things in the way it is they
don't have that analytical mind to
decide what is right or wrong yet bill
de blasio's parents
fought and funded the sandinistas in
nicaragua
and then this guy became mayor of new
york city
his parents helped over he his parents
helped finance and
like they were part of the considered
like a che guevara type for the the
communist sandinistas is overthrowing
nicaragua now this guy you know ran the
the most important city in america i
mean it's not what sound what you're
saying to people
sounds like crazy right-wing conspiracy
theory they're like this is insane this
is the third nobody has a 30-year plan
there's a 30-year plan there's a 50-year
plan it's playing out in front of people
and they they just refuse at any point
to connect very obvious dots
you know and it becomes incredibly
frustrating from the other side because
at some point like you you and i patrick
is the same way you have natural
precluding patrick always talks about
being a synergist bringing people
together make the argument i'm kind of
at the point where i you know what
sink or swim
you know the information's out there
read it or don't i don't care i tried
now it's time to move on
that's kind of where i'm at i fall more
into the catalyst category than the
synergist but i have nothing but respect
for the synergist you guys have patience
that i just don't have
so i i don't know like the information
is out there well i want to talk about
this before we run out of time patrick
is you know they made a chinese rambo
yeah right and so let me let me explain
this to you
when i was young i had a poster rambo in
my head
and i had a poster of arnold
schwarzenegger right and these were my
influence that's what made me who i was
today commandos special ops but right
now they made a a chinese
rainbow and look guys if you guys view
this he's holding the chinese flag as
he's coming in on a raid right it's very
propaganda so what i'm saying to you is
this man
that chinese pride
is growing
they have the strongest
they have the strongest present in the
last 50 years china pride is through the
roof right now
look at where we are
we're protesting jokes
outside yeah
go back go back to that article you were
on the business and said article so
here's a chinese propaganda film about
the the defeat of the us army is set to
become the country's highest grossing
film ever the battle at lake chang jin
has made 769 million dollars in uh since
release in china on september 30th
in the state funded movie outgunned
chinese troops beat their us foes during
the korean war battle chinese box
china's box office is the biggest in the
world meaning this film is also the
biggest
in the world john cena probably starred
in it yeah he's probably crying
somewhere if you're in china
why wouldn't you do this meaning why
wouldn't you do a rambo why wouldn't you
do a rocky why wouldn't you do that's
not the debate that's not the debate
right the debate is we did that in the
80s right rocky versus russia
rocky i mean rambo versus russians in
vietnam we did it and what did it build
it built our culture we built our pride
in our people but what i'm saying the
debate is now is that
china
is doing that so what i'm saying is they
have
you know a a present that's very
effective right now they're taking a
national playbook national pride what's
going on so what i'm saying is that
country is growing
in ideology right and it's it is
infectious throughout
the world because now they're employing
soldiers right they have their first
soldiers i've i read somewhere china has
their first soldiers four deployed now
to hold ground in in certain regions
never done china and russia that can
circle the globe
you saw that the missiles right so these
missiles are so dangerous because
they're subsonic missiles that can
dude
they can hug the terrain of the earth
let me explain to you what that means
it's almost impossible to pick up
radar-wise
right we when we go in on infiltration
we would we would um
we call a map of the earth we'll get low
on the radar and we'll just circ you
know basically follow terrain it's
almost
can't pick us up what they have is this
capability now
subsonic missiles you know what i mean
and china has that
and the american military have that too
i don't you know i can't talk too much
about what the military has but we have
some
but they have some advanced technology
now and they have the technology that
made us who we were
drones
we left it all
there was an episode on rogan where he
had the cia guy mike baker it was like
right literally right after you were on
and this is some of the stuff they were
discussing i don't know if you saw that
we left our weapons in afghanistan so
now think about china owns afghanistan
because they uh they're they're working
with the taliban now right they own
pakistan there's a road
from china through pakistan to in
afghanistan and now they they have a
direct route into kabul which will open
up the corridor into the middle east
where we have no eyes and ears on
anymore and they're building a supply
chain all the way to the tip of africa
and not not to say to iran with their
nuclear weapons
and in their hate towards americans i
mean they openly said it
two before i literally go kill myself um
can i can we maybe get a little silver
lining
from all this i mean like you're
literally the most intense guy i've ever
met but how do you stay positive what
what do you look at what are your
outlets i think life's good i think
instead of uh
rapping out of that way with the two
minutes that we have
uh uh uh because
we may i have a mastermind uh right now
i have to be right on time with this
that we're doing
um
two this has been great i wish we had
two more hours really enjoyed the
conversation uh i think we have some
conversations we'll have off uh uh
uh uh
you know the podcast that we can have
some follow-up conversations together
your energy your spirit fits the culture
here what we're doing man just love what
you stand for love what you got going on
uh i think two hours is not enough but
unfortunately that's the only time that
we have here today uh gang if you
enjoyed this podcast give it a thumbs up
we are 800 subs away from 100 000 subs
this last week's been an explosive uh
week for the podcast i think it was the
biggest week
we had in subs and we will have the
hundredth episode that won't be this
week but it'll be next week and we will
not be yes i'll answer them real quick
10 seconds the silver lining is we got
men willing to fight we got these guys
that's the silver line it ain't over
and we got a guy that takes uber about
that
very few makes us very very safe so adam
everything's going to be all right i
hope so i mean seriously you don't have
anything to worry about as long as uber
and lyft is here it's going to be all
right so gang thank you for tuning in
too thank you for tuning in as well
thank you everybody we'll see you next
tuesday have a great weekend bye bye bye
bye
you